is it trashy if your dad took you to the
prison he works at to get a free haircut
[Applause]
that looks great thanks so much take
care guys now who would cut the hair
would it be an inmate or would it be uh
like a barber that they hired
an inmate
It's gotta be a lead that's crazy
I'm sure you skipped a lollipop too on
the way out the door I think some good
Dan get your tickets for all the cities
on the state trashy tour and are you
garbage.com welcome so another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out the girl to be classy
after just a big old piece of trash I'm
your hostage Foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
hoodies in the new edition she's
upstairs getting plowed by somebody okay
I don't know what's going on all right
my co-host is coming at you right next
to me I'm trying to sneak one in on him
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman and he is not
to be trifled with in the Board Room or
the bedroom okay KJ Kevin James Ryan
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure your rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time I ain't got to tell
nobody that
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang you
go over there it's a goddamn party well
over 10 000 members of that yes sir and
the second greatest website of all time
are you garbage.com get your ticks for
the live shows some T-shirts some Zippo
style lighters added a Philly show
Philly come out let's sell that baby out
also added a third Toronto show get out
of here get out of here
it shout out to the Canucks baby and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the old magic
man back there rocking the shorts lately
showing the Gams giving up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen everybody what
up dudes what up T-Bone I'm stoked we
got the good homie in the crib man fun
day it is Grandpa chocolate chip ice
cream get a whoopie pie in you let's
have a good time I tell you man he's
like a breath of fresh air when he comes
in the weather's turned a little bit
Damon complaining I'm a big complainer
I'm worried about flesh-eating diseases
I'm not worried about the flesh eating
sometimes this happens I get mistook for
a warrior I wanna I wanna I mean I worry
about things well you still were like
Hey Joe how are you a flash eating
disease that's not not a word that's a
worry no I said I was like did you guys
hear about this because we were talking
heat the temperature by the way I'm
about to have a child I'm complaining
Foley's over there being like you hear
it's 180 in Texas Babies Can't Survive
everything's dying and so I was trying
to yes I am and and supposedly you were
riffing Jerry I'm not concerned but
evidently the uh what do you call the
muscles the oysters oysters yeah are
causing flesh-eating diseases the
ligaments but I don't need the hoof I
don't eat oysters I think you're in the
clear I don't worry about flesh eating
but I thought it was just a topic but
this happens to me a lot in my life
where I'll be like this uh what time
does the show start don't worry don't be
nervous and I'm like wow I'm just
wondering what time this year is like
the agent on Seinfeld
Oh Katie yes exactly yeah yeah yeah stop
freaking out yeah gotcha I'm freaking
out you got to worry about the Chinese I
think more for the kid
world war three that's what I'd worry
about the ocean I'm between two Looney
Tunes
AI climate change don't worry about
Skynet baby it's a nice day open the
door take a step back don't worry about
the claims Casino you'll be all right we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today he was
just here with the misses yeah but he's
got a [__] brand new special out
right now on a YouTube page enough for
everybody give it up for jolten Joe list
everybody
the best I appreciate you guys having me
I know it's a very close I was just here
wow what do you love it buddy your whole
family
[Laughter]
freaking out list uh this is Christ that
I was worried about but yeah please
check out the special enough for
everybody I I got demonet they're
censoring me I'm trying to do the
censorship bad boy comedy I said the c
word I thought it was pretty innocuous
but they they got me they got ya
[Laughter]
buddy that thing's cooking man yeah
congratulations congratulations if you
haven't listened to I'm sure or watch a
lot of people out there go [__] check
it out he's one of the you're cranking
them out it seems like every three weeks
you're everywhere oh thanks yeah it's
it's three and three and a half-ish
years so um I feel pretty good so yeah
go check it out please for the love of
Pete I got a baby to feed one of the
absolute best comedians working in the
goddamn movie star for Christ's sake
what are you doing here it's Hollywood
I wish yeah we made a film I'm working
on another documentary film I'll hit you
guys back up to come back
he's gonna move in here in a couple of
weeks because I'm dying too this is
better than my Empire your studio is
bigger than my parents house I grew up
in a smaller house than this yeah really
this guy bar might maybe close yeah
honestly it's bigger than my apartment
it's bigger than my apartment yeah I
think square footage is probably bigger
here than my parents house we had a yard
it's pretty good look at you all right
let's be good I don't know what you're
worried about it don't give us water in
there it's pretty good by the way I had
a I had a sighting of the list not that
long ago oh yeah I think I was hopping
out of a cab out in the neighborhood
there and it was you and about five or
six of your family members they were
scurrying down the street trying to get
to a cookie place before it closed
that's right ship City that's right
Chip city and they weren't waiting for
each other man there was somebody in the
back with a stroller I don't think they
got anything my brother-in-law's name is
Chip and we went in there and I did a
big I did a big thing it was they hated
me I was like guys I want everyone to
guess this guy's name Gary and the three
of them would just stare like this
and I went come on one guess and that
one guy went
chip yeah we all went crazy and there
was no oh we gotta do that that day yeah
there was no emotion we were all right
hey buddy we're closing in 10 minutes
but I think they were catching a train
and we wanted to get our big cookie
they're all right man shout out to Chip
city they're fantastic they're fun
highly recommend Chip city but yeah
they're coming back tell me this isn't
uh hurtful my niece is going to college
okay I think Pace University and uh
they're moving her in and so I'm like
we're gonna go to the Mets game we're
gonna go to The Cellar we'll get some
wings we'll go to uh The High Line
families in town yeah and uh they booked
the morning train Saturday morning
move-in is 2 p.m and they got an evening
train back oh in and out that's that
ain't out that ain't great that's
holiday weekend I might ask oh yikes not
even like hey let's grab a dinner let's
anything we gotta get back the snow's
coming
the roads will be terrible Jesus in and
out what they do but they would have had
to get a hotel and stuff they really
didn't like that chip bin huh maybe
they'd have to get it you might think
well a hotel is very pricey holiday
weekend I have a an additional Studio
office downstairs I have a bed it's a
basement it's a basement but it's it's
furnished
it looks like what kind of beds in there
a nice bet I'll tell you what it's a
very nice bed it's a full-size bed and
when Sarah the reason it's downstairs we
ordered a bed frame and I forgot about
the existence of full-size bed I just
thought of twin and queen so I was like
we have a queen because I used to have a
twin
as an adult yikes and uh
keep your nudie bags wait well what
Adrian a twin
I'd rather not say
35.
yeah you and Sarah weren't living
together yet were you no we had separate
places okay and both you would sleep in
them when she would sleep over no I
stayed at her place okay and what I
thought she had a futon she had a full
but I thought it was a queen so I was
like we gotta get a bed that's how
trashy you are I know and it was
mattress on the ground situation so I
was like we got to get a frame we're
married we're men with jobs Jerry
so I ordered and I was like well we have
a queen and Sarah's like are you sure
and I'm like yeah because mine's a twin
so this has got to be a queen so they
showed up and built the bed frame the
two guys and then they put the mattress
and they were like this isn't you know
this is the wrong size right and I had
to be like this of course yeah this is a
bit I'm doing so this is a sleeping bag
it's like the new mattress is on its way
and so we slept for like one full year
on a bed a queen-size bed frame with a
full size so Chip and the family would
have had to stay in the basement in a
full-size bed with a queen size bed
frame am I have that right no the bed
frame now we've laid our bought it okay
so now the frame and Mattress match on
the floor on the mattress I'm on chip
side yeah no [__] thanks for the cookies
Yeah Christmas well we call it the Mets
game
[Laughter]
to get it wait till that security guard
turns his back then we're all clear so
all you gotta do is hand out a couple of
Flyers after the show but now I have my
niece living in the city that's cool
show her all the Chipotles and Starbucks
there you go [__] John Q America over
here
all the ins and outs of New York City
uh we wanted to ask you about uh because
it's the you know we're creeping towards
the end of the summer here as I said in
the beginning the weather changes and
you just get that feeling of the first
day of school back to school baby did
that excite you as a kid I was I would
probably say you were a little worried I
was nervous about going back to school
always but it depends on what year we're
talking High School I really came into
my own I under I was really moving and
shaking I had friends I was very popular
in high school believe it or not I
believe that and so um that high school
I was like I couldn't wait to get back
and see everybody I had like an audience
and I was an athlete so that was
exciting but Elementary School I was
definitely [__] my pants yeah I
wasn't a fan of that either no it was
nerve-wracking but summer also could be
a bummer because like I just got dropped
off at my grandmother's we didn't go to
like it could be lonely those like
Elementary School junior high days of
like today seemed like a hundred hours
long and you were just [__] there
yeah somebody was watching you or by
yourself in your house no car nothing
yeah there would be times where my aunt
would come and watch because both my
parents worked full-time so like if my
aunt came we would run around the
neighborhood we I grew up in a
neighborhood with like a lot of kids
that was fun but a lot of the days yeah
it was drop off at your grandmother's
house and there was no kids in that
neighborhood no none it was like a lot
of prices right with with my grandmother
oh hey don't hate that air conditioning
oh I can't imagine no no no air
conditioning no and a lot of indoor
smoking too just change that yeah
ripping heaters and watching Bob Barker
and somehow my grandmother would be on
the phone a hundred percent of the day
like she just would have folk like like
four hour phone calls just talking [__]
that's what they do and they get older
yeah they start ripping on everybody
yeah maybe that's what uh I'll be but
she would sit on her leg and then she
would get up and go yeah and like limp
around because she just sat on a foot
for the day
what would she be rocking probably too
hot no AC not rocking a house coat yeah
but she certainly didn't have shorts on
she's in there in a two-piece I think it
might have been like a bathrobe thing
maybe okay background a nightgown
nightgown yeah I heard a d at the end of
that for some reason my count is it not
a nightgowned it sounds like something
they do to get there a gown like a ball
like a a ball gown yeah gown gown I also
with the three of us we're not all great
at words I don't think we should be the
we're not the authority on how to
pronounce words I said Knight there's no
D in now it's nightgown yeah that gound
now I just thought I just found out it
was wheelbarrow
yeah I still say Barrel yeah I say
Barrel too yeah it's a barrel with
wheels yeah it's stupid I don't know
what they're talking about somebody was
being a [__] but yeah I'm trying to
picture I think some kind of
long thing one PC sure type of thing I'm
saying where was your grandfather was he
at work he worked yeah he'd go to work
he'd come back and bring my McDonald's a
lot he smoked as well there you go he
had real bad cops I remember it was a
lot of wet
I definitely picture dirt on your face
the whole time for some reason yeah it
was a tough how a lot of cats it was a
lot of cat fur and cigarettes it wasn't
great not a great atmosphere and also I
think when they eventually moved it was
the kind of place you'd take pictures
off the wall and there was just that
yellow stain around and my uncle who's
my age he grew up that's a red flag that
ain't great Joe he grew up in the house
and he became a fireman and when he had
his physical exam they were like how
long have you been smoking and he's like
I've never smoked in my life and they're
like yeah yeah that's not good so
how did it get to who's what's the age
difference uh summer memories huh
summer nights man I thought lacrosse
games like Jesus Christ what was the
what's the age difference yeah your
uncle's the same age he's he's actually
four years older than me or five years I
think he's five years when it comes to
uncles that's the same age but yeah my
and my cousin you wouldn't call him
uncle whatever well Dale I still call
him Uncle Dale when you were a kid you
called him Uncle David no no as a kid I
just called him mean he was very my
uncle and we're very close now and we
have been for many years my uncle and my
cousin who he's his uncle too and they
are two months apart or something I
guess five months apart but they used to
crank in the summer they would crank up
the AC and they had like the little
plug-in thing in the bedroom we I guess
everyone had AC in their bedroom but not
the living room they would plug it in
and then they would steal my blankets at
night as like a gag because I'd fall
asleep first I was younger and I would
wake up like shivering and I used to
sleep with dirty clothes as blankets
I've been there and uh one time the same
uncle we were fighting about something
and I caught him I came out and he was
putting thumbtacks in the bottom of my
sneakers what yeah and if I hadn't
caught him in the ACT I would be like in
a wheelchair right now I think
imagine that it's like ripping your foot
across a thumbtack
sure man plus a pneumonia too yeah I
mean it was it was not it really sounds
like your family does not like you yeah
well we were like brothers you know they
taught me the ways of the world and how
to be worried about flesh-eating
diseases did you pay for the cookies by
the way do you spring for the cookies
for everybody I spring for a lot of
things I can't speak to the cookies
specifically okay I'll do some buying
but my family is running out of town on
you though they're these kind of people
that they probably resold those cookies
when they got home I think because I'm
younger they think like we got to pay
him back or whatever and uh so yeah
there's a lot of like let me buy dinner
and then they like leave a hundred under
the plant or something that kind of
stuff which is very sweet but you're
like I make money I have money I know I
have that I have that same Dynamic too
it's like now that you're I'm 37 and
it's like they're still like you know
let me get it for you I'm like I I do
well I have a job I make money it's okay
I can I can buy water ice for everybody
I get that at 47 but I was a loser for
so long of course yeah up until so long
yeah that's the thing is uh there's
psychological studies your family sees
you as who you are as a kid for sure I
still get [__] because I chickened out
on Space Mountain 30 years ago and they
still make fun of me and I'm like well
I've been in a helicopter in Iraq since
then like I've really I've lived sure
I'm not you know I'm sure I'm worried
about flesh-eating diseases and AI but
I'm out here I'm not on a goddamn
coaster if you want me to you hear that
chip yeah I sprinted from the subway
into the studio but I'm here
do you really run places
no I don't I don't run places but I will
run from people if it gets I haven't run
in a while but I've had a couple people
where I'm like all right take care I'll
just talk on out of here
and I imagine we all would I mean I had
two guys I mean I've told the story I've
had two guys like screaming in my face
like yeah I would back off of that for
sure I'm a big Runner that's why I wear
the sneakers goddamn track star you're
goddamn right what were your events by
the way I ran in track I ran the mile
and is this all four years you were you
it was track yeah so I ran cross country
I was planning to play baseball as a big
baseball guy but my going into my
freshman year going into that season I
was uh ineligible because I failed two
classes and the classes were
algebra and introduction to computers
took algebra in eighth grade no this is
ninth grade that's still pretty good I
think that's what it is is it yeah no I
was like eighth or ninth grade I feel
like I took that my senior year no I
never like people took calculus I never
got to calculus oh [__] that [__] yeah I
was uh not not good that wasn't my cup
of tea either yeah but I failed intro to
computers which was really humiliating
but anyway so I was ineligible to figure
out Oregon Trail I mean it was it was
tough I don't know there was a mouse
involved and I couldn't do it I'm never
gonna need this this is nonsense I'm a
books man but uh because I was
ineligible my my cross-country coach was
also the track coach he said you can be
on the track team you just can't compete
but we'll let you practice with us but I
was I couldn't try out for a team I was
ineligible for so I just did that but uh
yeah so I went cross-country winter Trek
Spring Track all all three seasons all
four years damn was the school good we
were unbelievable baby we didn't our
Spring Track we didn't lose a meet from
1990 to like 2001. we were printing and
I was in 12 Seasons 12 conference
championships the teams Dad yeah it's
all right accomplished [__] athlete
over here yeah my coach is like a Hall
of Fame coach black shout out still
around Hall of Famer do you have any of
those trophies in the apartment no I got
no High School anything got rid of it
all sure it's in a box somewhere I'm
sure my parents have it in the Box Camp
let's talk about liquid
let's talk about getting rid of that
boring old water you're drinking drink
something that looks like a tall boy
baby something that's gonna get you laid
Yeah you know what I'm saying gang
healthy beverage is right around the
corner with liquid depth and it looks
cool and you look cool drinking it do
yourself a favor rip into one yeah uh I
remember the first time I had liquid
death I was crazy hung up hey dude I was
crazy hungover it was at the bottom of a
cooler I reached down because I don't
like sparkling water but they got the
regular wall I got the Mountain Water
the straight up artisanal water I
cracked this thing baby it cured about
15 hangovers in two minutes dude forget
all that just rest in peaches all right
yeah it's fantastic their cans have the
coolest art on them and might just be
the inspiration for your next tattoo if
you're a biker they're also knocking out
of the park with the merge grab yourself
a hoodie a hat or even a flat that looks
like a casket 30 calories in this that's
it it's not bad damn you can find liquid
death uh liquid deaths healthy beverages
on Amazon or the retailer near you are
you garbage listeners get 20 off their
first liquid death apparel purchase
available exclusively at liquiddeath.com
garbage exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com garbage do it gang okay
let me tell you about VPN tell me a
little something about VPN because I
know you're a private guy you got the
tape on your thing you don't want people
looking at you when you're watching your
videos
VPN baby yeah you shouldn't be surfing
the net without it keep your identity a
secret keep what you're doing in your
pocket you know what I'm saying every
time you connect to an unencrypted
Network like when you're at a hotel or a
cafe or any hacker on that Network can
steal all your personal information
expressvpn keeps you protected by
creating a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
there you go so hackers can't steal your
[__] log into your webcam watch you
whaling on yourself never get me what
you're doing hey expressvpn works on
your laptop phone tablet and more so you
can protect yourself on any device uh I
used it when I go over to Germany
because you can log in and get all
different kind of you get all different
kind of videos sure real real dark web
get weird in Dussel doors uh so secure
your online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com garbage that's
expressvpnexp r e s s vpn.com garbage
you can get an extra three months for
free oh they're giving away the vpns
over there expressvpn.com garbage do it
gang now back to that gosh darn show
back to the show is your room still set
up at your parents house
a little bit it's not like it was but
there's still a room with the bed and
there's a couple there's a couple of
like my photos hanging in there but it's
not like I used to have pictures and
posters on every inch of the thing and I
always know how do you guys feel about
this because my sister she was resentful
because she moved out and they
immediately turned it into like a family
room a den or whatever my bedroom
remained like a bedroom for years and
she thought that was insulting to her
but I was like no no this is insulting
to me
I went to pursue comedy and they're like
leave his bedroom the way back he's
going to be back I've seen his closer
he'll be back is this on the second
floor well we only had one floor right
that's right just one little no basement
is underground no basement no stairs
right it looks like exactly like the
Monopoly house yeah it's green it's the
same size the roof and house is the same
color
but to me it was like they were like
don't touch anything he ain't going into
it yeah I mean I didn't take offense I
just thought like no you're in the bed
my sister moved out and they're like
she's gone she's good she's okay in the
world yeah this idiot thinks he's
Seinfeld he's coming back I'd be more
pissed if they if they redid it I I
wouldn't care I have no sentimental
value to any of that stuff my room is
still somewhat the same it's still my
room yeah yeah mine mine too I suppose
but she lives a couple blocks away she's
fine there you go what was your style
like in high school I could see you like
a jean jacket kind of guy my style has
not changed at any point ever in my life
I've been wearing the same exact thing
came out of the womb with glasses
Bruins t-shirts jeans and running
sneakers 100 away you could go to any
the only thing you might find is the
long sleeve tee with the short sleeve
over it love that man that was great for
my body like it it pads the man I was a
chubby kid's bread and butter right
there that was nice and um a pair of
cargo shorts you go back maybe the
shorts have changed I would have jean
shorts and I always felt this way about
shorts no one ever emails you to tell
you the style changed they like I would
wear jeans shorts and then they'd be
like look at this dinner with jean
shorts you're like [__] I guess I gotta
go I gotta go car go and then one day
they were like gargoyle whoa wait were
you wearing jean shorts that weren't cut
offs just regular jean shorts everybody
did hemmed up ones like you buy yeah
never they were never cool yeah they
were cool they were cool when were they
cool
that's Dad's wore that [__] I'm telling
you they were cool it was cool for sure
yeah like fifth grade when I was in
fifth grade whatever that is 93 92. yeah
mid 90s were cool and then cut offs yeah
nah even yeah but cut off cuddles were
not not saying they weren't cool they
were cool but Gene regular hemmed jean
shorts bought at the store were in
fashion those are big I have somewhere
there's a picture of me I've posted it
before playing league basketball with
the jersey and jean shorts on picture
day
I take it back they are cool
uh yeah somewhere that exists me and
jean shorts and America dress shoes on
he's got the high black socks
slipping all over the course
my list to stay on your toes coach black
screaming it was uh yeah I mean I don't
know what happened that day but I had
jeans short but jean shorts were the
thing and then cargo were cool
car goes I remember there was a point
and it's obviously aged you know uh
different but there was a point where if
you had khaki shorts without cargo
Pockets that was like loserville yeah
like you were like that was like what
your dad would wear if you had a set of
Bermudas on that was like you couldn't
go to school with that you had to have
pockets wasn't Bugle Boy Something boy
was real those were shorts
jeans yeah then they started making his
shorts were you guys wearing shorts to
high school you wearing shorts in high
school yeah summertime never
um probably not Toby well you were in
short junior high for sure really Junior
High cargo shorts and like a slipknot
t-shirt or something I don't think I
ever wore [__] shorts since yeah I
wore shorts but yes basically my style
haircut 100 the same it was very a
little other than jean shorts at a
basketball game there's not a lot of
looking and being like look at my pants
I never pegged my pants I never you know
spiked my hair I never had your bow
whatever where did where would you go
shop back to school shopping was it like
Marshall was it anywhere or your mom
just would be like I got you three pairs
of jeans this is what you're wearing
Sears because my aunt worked at Sears I
worked at Sears later also and I think
we did the the discount to really keep
it in the family these lists oh everyone
in my family worked at Sears my dad
worked at Sears for a little while we
were refrigerators the crazy thing is
his aunt's three years younger
we were Sears filings filene's basement
I worked at finland's also Jesus did you
yeah a lot of retail gigs but uh yeah
definitely Sears filene's basement
Marshalls will there be a big day where
you all go out you're like we're going
load the whole list up in the car
absolutely yeah yeah could you pick it
out or she was like this is what you're
getting type D no we would pick it out
and my mother did a good job of trying
to get whatever was cool yeah my mother
like I didn't realize that money was
touched she was very good about being
like okay well that's what we gotta get
I mean sometimes she'd be like no you're
getting this but I had bad genes most of
my life probably still now people are
still upset about my jeans well you're
rocking I guess Levi whatever Sears had
Levi's I think were all right back then
it was different yeah but then like they
started getting they started getting
like a little bit of flair to them and
like just regular straight dad jeans
were like Levi they weren't the coolest
yeah you had to go to button fly at a
certain point no I never had a button
fly never not wrong right yeah anything
like I said anything kind of changed I
was like nah and I had some ripped jeans
that I would wear but there was like a
natural rip there you go you're the best
yeah we didn't buy ripped jeans and were
you a party kid in high school you were
boozing in high school I assume right no
I didn't know after high school no shoes
no I was a I was on the straight and
narrow path would you go to the parties
and stuff like that the high school
parties and run from the cops and all
that [__] no we didn't have a good thing
my friends were uh yeah wait for the gun
to go off
I was like a track guy and so a lot of
my friends were like really uh
valedictoriany I was like the dummy
loser and one group of friends and then
I had other friends that were a little
tougher but we never went to parties we
started I started drinking right after
high school but like they smoked
cigarettes and would dip
but I didn't participate in that and
then we didn't go to parties we hadn't
we've had poker games we were big like
poker Friday night was like poker night
or we'd go to the mall and walk around
or whatever could have swore you just
said you were cool in high school I'm
telling you these were the cool guy I
mean they were smoking but poker's cool
we played poker for an 80 year old man
sure I don't think you know how high
school works we but it was not a big
party it's got a parties and fingertips
this is aces one-eyed faces couple
parties I mean that was always the
classic that was always the classic
thing in the in like the 80s and 90s
High School movies the Nerds that got
the courage to go to the party it was
always the poker it started at the poker
game like we should be out there we
should be going to the party oh they
were having they're drinking like a w
root beer and smoking cigars well
sometimes I mean I also had friends like
junior senior they were like in the
coolest band they were called Weldon
Hill and they like kicked ass they were
like I was at the cool band guys I I
swung with the best of them
the whole guy the whole gang you named
the place I was there but we only had a
few party parties but
um yeah maybe there was a lot and I
wasn't invited yeah am I wrong here
you're not right leave me hanging I'm
not I'm a green I there was probably
more parties that you did not get
invited to for sure but also Ryan poker
right after high school we started have
more parties and I was the party house
but not till after high school because
my parents would go away and then we'd
have everybody over we had like raging
crazy parties like ages like 18 19 20 21
like all those like this is crazy it's
loud we're listening to music all that
stuff people are hooking up in my
parents bedroom that came after high
school for me okay as soon as high
school ended I was like a piece of [__]
because I started comedy right away
right so I started hanging out with like
35 year old deadbeat yeah yeah it was it
went South fast did you hear about that
list party was not sad music
somebody Got Fingered somewhere I
pictured just a bunch of like 42 year
old open mikers hanging out that's what
it was I mean all your high school
friends like who are those guys Lenny
Clark passed out in your parents bed
foreign
it was fast it was a quick transition
and it would be a thing like I would
bump into people or I would have like
friends for high school friends come to
the show and I'm like we all go out
after and then being like what are you
doing like these guys are like balding
[__] hey let's let me borrow 10
bucks but to me like I was like that's
John fish look at that and they were
like that's just a 35 year old guy
that's a guy who's unsuccessful at the
moment um yeah so it was a weird
transition I guess but yeah I remember I
do remember and my parents probably
thought this too because like I would be
like hey I'm heading to New York City
with a couple guys and it would be like
a 50 year old man sure driving me to New
York City like it would be a guy my
dad's age
that's very quickly after graduating my
friends were the same age as my parents
my parents never questioned it they're
like you're going to New York with this
man who's a peer of ours have fun get
some cookies mom dad you know Dom my
Herrera right
we're going away for the weekend he's a
good kid
I don't say this oh shout out to Dahmer
love dumb oh me too the best
well yeah it was it was odd I guess but
I was cool I swear to God
[Laughter]
a few parties but but
you threw my 20s
go to the let's have a small hand
because we're funny guys sure who needs
the big hoopla yeah he makes the hoopla
yeah exactly we are the hoopla I had
that last night we did a lot it's girls
and good times huh we had a live
Tuesdays with stories and direct the
poker chips and let's get wild I'm still
down for a poker
I guarantee those cigars were just
pretzel rods too we spoke like Philly
blunts yeah but we drank baby there you
go we would drink and you know get naked
run around I was a big Steeler of signs
and stuff I I got after it you were you
were Mischief a little bit right you
pulled some high Jinks in the school and
yes absolutely we had a my senior year
we did a lot of fun stuff one time me
and my friend Jeffrey Andrews was
hilarious so I think as a school teacher
now we did a protest it was a leap year
so it was a February 29th and so we made
posters and signs and said make leap
year every year or one more day equals
one more day
she's really tore it up but that was
funny this is during school hours guys I
mean that's wild
I know what you do with the sun you walk
during the school with the signs yeah it
was funny and people walked by going
what is this it was kind of alternative
comedy like an Andy Kaufman kind of
thing I think Joe slowly realizing he
was a dork
yeah people were like that's wild one
time oh that's fine hey watch out this
guy's making signs over here everybody
one time we went into the home ec class
and we made we made muffins for
everybody no no we switched the sugar
with the salt
we stole it I'm not making that recipe
work we stole an egg that's who Flay's
gonna fall stolen egg we stole an egg
wait till you hear the fun surprise
you're still not doing time for it
stolen eggs we had a courtyard in our
school we dropped the eggs so it it
broke then we went to the gymnasium
stole three orange cones we put the
cones around the egg
so people all day every student would
walk by and just look at even the
teachers the teachers the adults every
group all right it's not just the
students they would say hey look at this
who'd put this there those often times
called it the heist of the century
that's pretty good
an egg
you know the town's really based on Joe
list
and we cut class
with permission obviously we cut class
but go to the library and read now would
you skip school would you would you dip
out I did so what would happen was I was
I had perfect attendance but I would
skip classes I would just go we would
leave or hide my girlfriend at the time
when I would go down into the boiler
room I found out you could open that
door and we would hide in the boiler
room and play cards and hang out
throughout an entire class which is
pretty quite a caper so but it's like
200 degrees in there it would be rather
be in class dude hey Tina come down here
a picture you're getting caught in the
gym what are you guys doing tonight
you're not smoking weed or nothing I
mean we weren't even like playing around
each other or anything like that we
literally just hung out it was quite
Innocent but it would be awkward because
at the end of the semester I would get
the perfect attendance award but also on
the report card it'd be like you missed
14 days of math 11 days of science so I
would have absences and perfect
attendance which was pretty wide that
reminds me of that Regan whether he's at
work building bikes and the guy takes
him into the wall he goes back the guy
finds a space between the two layers of
drywall and then he just gets back in
there and it's ringing the guy and
they're like does he goes how good is
this
it's a great bit
and we'd hide out in the dumpster all
day
shout out to Brian Regan have you guys
had him on no I would love to have him
he's an all-time First comedy show I've
ever seen yeah was uh Brian Regan he's
incredible Tower Theater yeah it was
great
um he was the first person to break it
because people started yelling out bits
at the end like Bob or Fig Newtons or
whatever
and he did it a little differently
obviously because the bit was from like
five years ago and he missed the line
and someone yelled out the actual line
that was on the special or the recording
and he's like yeah I'm he's like it's
dead like you do it different every time
and that like blew my mind I was like Oh
I thought he was just like read it like
it was like soap it had to be perfect
every time no he's incredible someone
asked us last night in our podcast who
your desert island special in mind is
Brian we got walked on the moon it's
great that's the thing about the
Cranberries is great crane grape crane
yeah yeah yeah [__] brilliant no he's
just killing he's awesome
um I don't know if we asked you this uh
do you drive in a school no I didn't
have my license till after school I got
a ride senior year I rode with my friend
Brendan O'Leary Everyone's an O'Leary oh
something yeah sure and what kind of car
was it oh I don't know maybe like a Ford
Taurus or something it certainly wasn't
a nice okay car but um yeah no I didn't
have my license till after in fact I
took my driver's test my senior year why
is that can I asked it was 16 up there
yeah and I think I was just first of all
in general I think 16 is too young to
drive a car I think it's insane that 16
year olds are driving did you think that
then
I think I did in general but I was my
thing was worried
come on I shouldn't be doing this I was
like I should change the the age or
whatever but I also everyone I knew had
cars so people would drive you around
and there wasn't a car available got it
too it's gonna be one of those deals so
I just wasn't in a big hurry your
parents each had a car though right yes
okay so I just felt like ah I don't know
it's not I'm not no I wasn't in a big
hurry I don't really know why I was
having a a good time and I was like I'll
get to that but you weren't taking the
bus like you're Junior and Senior year
somebody was driving you're picking yeah
yeah all right cool yeah I took the bus
like freshman sophomore year was the bus
stop close to you
uh end of the street I think okay yeah
but uh I then I went and took it my
senior year and I failed the driver's
test and this is so brutal because I
took it during school hours because that
was the only time and I came back in I
remember the psychology class we walked
in and everyone went there yeah they
started clapping like like Henry after
his first trial he popped your cherry
and uh I walked in and I had to be like
I didn't uh I didn't pass man and so the
Applause died I just had to sit there
like a dick
I got my license now folks and I can
really cook
ten and two hey Mario Andretti out there
I'm really cooking on these streets
drive like a lane it wasn't until I
graduated I started doing comedy I was
like okay now I gotta yeah I gotta get
somewhere yeah yeah for sure
a damn yeah
um why what two I think we did it with
no we did it with Norman and Morel a big
obviously you're a big sign guy big
Seinfeld guy as are we who do you think
the best Standalone one episode
character is that's only made one
appearance the best one-off character
boy that's tough because so many of the
best ones come back a couple times at
least one off
gold there's a couple of standouts you
said one last night one last night I'm
I'm it's got to be the Moyle if you go
back and watch that every word out of
his mouth is a laugh really the more the
moyal is every word's a punch or Bookman
Bookman obviously
bookman's fun
God damn I got a really uh think about
this one Todd gack
that's a great episode around him but
his whole thing is very funny
um oh the uh Jack right Tonya Harding
lady is pretty amazing the understudy
yes the understudy she's pretty amazing
but Miller's amazing of course
um yeah boy one one time o-t-o-t-o one
time one time only that's also the one I
I just saw I was watching yesterday who
the guy's great was when they volunteer
with the old people the guy Jerry gets
whose teeth fall out and they take his
records same thing every word out of his
mouth is going for a laugh yeah boy I
wish I had time to think about this one
but we'll be right back
and cut hmm
[Music]
think about it call us later
um but we did it with Norman and I think
it's everybody come everybody falls on
Bookman and the Moyle for a lot of the
times yeah with fiori Donnelly yeah but
here's an underrated one
Elaine's dad oh yeah that's up there I
mean yeah one of my all-time favorite
lines is we'll tell him we're frightened
and we have to leave yeah I mean that's
pretty amazing which one are you
supposed to be the funny guy yeah yeah
that's him he's the comedian were you
packing were you so you were excited for
school
yeah I think I'm in high school yeah in
high school I loved it my junior senior
year probably sophomore year two I loved
every day of high school I thought it
was just the best I was a very bad
student but I loved seeing everybody I
loved lunch I really hit a stride there
and um were you buying your lunch or
were you bringing it I I bought lunch
and this is my life you're gonna find
this not believable 100 of the days of
school my lunch was four chocolate chip
cookies and a lemonade
I believe that yeah I was not I was like
a soft pretzel and an iced tea type guy
or something but you'd have breakfast in
the morning at the house right it's a
couple bowls the fact that I don't have
uh diabetes is wild I just ate a bunch
of cereal and then I would go we had
lunch at like 11 30 a.m it would be four
cookies a lemonade then I would go to
the rest of school and run like seven
eight miles on take it off that make a
home and have dinner yeah and then it
would be like a McDonald's or Burger
King typically really or spaghetti mac
and cheese were your parents buying the
Burger King and McDonald's that much
yeah we went to Burger King a lot Big
Burger King family did your mom cook at
all she cooked I had Burger King she
would cook whatever I was very picky eat
it she would eat they would have
whatever the [__] I don't know you got
away with that as a kid as a as a very
picky to the mom that they get sick of
it they go just let them get [__]
Burger King and that's who would take
you to Burger King thank my mother
father yeah whoever so they come home
from work driving Drive diving back and
forth to work come home she'd make a
dinner for the family and then have to
run out to Burger King to get you Burger
King yeah someone would take me to
whoever wasn't cooking would go and
drive me to Burger King trying to make
him feel bad about it again by the way
you laying it on a big guy Burger King
was a finsky I mean it was like 4.80 two
cheeseburgers fry and we would go to
Papa Gino's a lot you know like that was
the big pizza joint sure a lot of pizza
and then at home if they cook it would
be mac and cheese you know rigatoni
marinara you would eat that stuff yeah
okay a lot of that maybe a taco Tuesday
occasionally love a taco Tuesday yeah
were you a taco salad guys a big taco
salad guys no I don't care for a taco
salad love it I like a salad I like a
taco I don't mix them what are they
doing together
all right we got Joe list here let's do
something [__] questions gang when
you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
uh patreon gets first crack at it that's
just the way we do it around here oh
speaking of school this is uh this is
from Dave the Barbarian brand new 10
homie shout out to you yeah you or
anyone know try to Nick you or anyone
you know try to nickname yourself I once
gave myself in sixth grade the nickname
D money but it never stuck oh wow I call
my best friend D Money D money's an easy
one is a good one yeah what did you ever
what would you did you have a nickname
or did you push for a nickname T-Bone
anything no again not certainly not in
school and comedy my friends don't call
me kids menu that was like hey it's good
which was fun my uncle had Dale the same
age one he's always called me the outlaw
or not maybe not always but since I
started drinking I like okay
he was trying to come up with Nick
before right as you walked in he was
coming up like the freak Joe Liz just
something like Outlaw the outlaw Joey
list I mean he still calls me like if we
call and it's like Ernest because that
last name is Campbell so I call him soup
and he said hey I say hey soup and he
goes hey Outlaw it's like it's not even
like hey The Outlaw yeah it's just what
he calls me that's like trucker Carlson
yes yeah yeah soup in The Outlaw it's
all right I'd watch that movie somebody
get Burt Reynolds on the phone
coming to a poker game near you and we
got after it too we could really get it
going yeah we got we got wild but um no
no self-imposed certainly no selfish we
need to walk down to the living room one
day and be like everyone call me
switchblade from now on no certainly not
um and no nickname I mean List they
would be like hey list or whatever maybe
a Joey Joey isn't it weird how they were
kids you grew up with that their last
name fit as a name and other ones didn't
like you know what I mean like lists
holy Ryan yeah people try to say Ryan
and it's like you're just confusing him
yeah like hey Ryan you're like what that
does it just doesn't work yeah but
you're like you're all last names only
that's holy yeah yeah my mom calls him
Foley but like two of my best friends
growing up Brad Kramer and Seth Collins
Kramer was Kramer obviously
doesn't work we could just call him Seth
yeah interesting
well in Boston everything's e Joey
Johnny or Philly's the same Kevin
whatever yeah yeah you put a little yeah
Put a Little Love on it you got to throw
it out there yeah my I mean Kippy stuck
from Keith Robinson but I hate it at the
moment but it just [__] it's just is
what it is interesting yeah I have a
thing where I can't I never call anybody
by their regular I'd like to have
something I do the same thing I love it
too yeah I got I just I don't know what
it is when you go to the doctors will
you say thanks Doc will you get him with
a dock or do you say doctor I mean I
don't go to the doctor very often so and
the last time I did it was a woman so I
don't know I don't think I'd do a duck
no no duck I I do it a lot I don't have
to reports there I feel like yeah but I
did it not that long ago with my
cardiologist but it was in the hallway I
feel like they're completely different
people from in the hallway to in the
room like I just happened to catch him
coming out I was back in my room in my
examination room and I went to pee and I
saw him in the hallway I'm like hey
what's going on Doc and he gave me shot
me a look like shut your fat [__]
mouth but then when he's in the room
he's doing materials crowd work he's
fantastic where are you from interesting
yeah first of all I should go to the
doctor more frequently here we go yeah
I'm just I'm like freaking out I gotta
check for flesh eating diseases
well I had some high BP last time I was
there it's not good but um yeah I don't
think I do a doc no doc okay okay yeah I
just brought this you're you're
obviously a big Boozer I was just in
Boston last weekend uh have you ever
been to O'Sullivan's Tapout like right
by the garden yes this is fantastic I
don't think there's an O I think it's
just solo that might be Sullivan I think
it's just Sullivan's but I had my first
legal drink there no [__] my 21st
birthday I saw the Washington Wizards
play the Celtics Jordan's last game in
Boston no [__] and I went to Sullivan's
and I was like this is my first beer
legally or whatever that place is all
right yeah that's a great day I was just
there recently when I went to
Springsteen so yeah such a hole in the
wall we were walking by we're like we
just need somewhere to grab a beer and I
look up it's like Sullivan's Taphouse
they claim the oldest sports bar or the
oldest there's some sort of thing they
got going and I was like damn this I
walk in it smells like a dive [__] ball
it's awesome it's a real [__] it's
great I love it great air that whole
area is so different from when I grew up
it's bananas yes I mean like now the
Stadium's like pristine yeah it looks
like a mall in LA or something like when
you walk up that and there used to be
like an elevated train there it was loud
it was it's a totally different spot but
yeah I know Sully's thanks I know
something I know
list these down in the Outlaws down here
in Sully's he's got his pants on his
head he's crazy list he's good too I
like this yeah
you know that story My First Open Mic I
said my last name is list l-i-s-t and
the guy was like you got it and he
brought me up he goes this next guy he's
a command Joe list dialest he thought
that was my last name which is hilarious
um yeah listing is Big that's fun that's
good
um but all right let's get into some
goddamn questions we burn all the
[__] time just hanging out uh let's
see here this one's from Alexander
speaking of Boston shout out that shout
out to him
have you ever called and complained to a
How's my driving sticker
no one to a lot I haven't I want to just
the other day I was walking there was a
Yellow Cab parked and I'm this guy now I
reached the stage he just took his
crumbled up a bag he was like having his
snack break and he just dropped it out I
hate that too the window I stopped and I
went uh you just throw your trash in the
ground like that that's what you do and
the guy I felt bad because I felt like
he actually spoke zero English and was
like
and then you just kind of kept drinking
and I was like wow what are you gonna do
but I did write down 4K 95 and I was
like I'm gonna I'm gonna really report
this guy and then like a half an hour
later I was in my notes and I was like
what am I doing I'm not doing that so
I'm getting there I'm like Progressive
I've dipped my toe in I'm always a
little bit paranoid if I do call it just
goes right to them like you [__]
[__] you know what I mean like pull
over you bald-headed whatever and I
gotta fight a guy on H Street I don't
want that
um ah come right in we'll uh we'll
discuss this further I've called 9-1-1
on the highway
because uh there was some lunatic on
driving one time and he like brake
checked me or something like that and
then sped off and he was like [__]
weaving through and we were I was
driving down the Jersey Turnpike I was
like [__] call 9-1-1 right and trying
to like pin him out but they never even
showed up wow [__] narc yeah Karen
Foley over here yeah already it's really
ratting up guys trying to have a good
time probably late for work or something
dropping by yeah uh all right let's see
here this one's still perfect this one's
from stay in the caddy shout out to stay
in the caddy never have one red has
anyone you known ever bought brought a
frozen pizza to Thanksgiving dinner
yikes that's I wouldn't hate it as I
love a frozen job you'll do Thanksgiving
right yeah my family I have done this at
Christmas dinner had a DiGiorno with
Sarah's family just cooking a DiGiorno
why because I didn't get enough to eat
they've we talked about this with Sarah
I think they eat like 400 calories a day
sure we did talk about that so I do
bring a du Journey because I didn't
mention it DiGiorno though yeah yeah I
guess for after like a stack of
digiornos that I'm cooking oh for like
okay not like
so dinner's over maybe this one goes up
to bed this one's watching TV hey I'm
gonna pop in a pizza
yeah they didn't go to bed it's like a
half hour later
dessert I have a solo DiGiorno like
Kevin McAllister just eating it but I've
I've done I haven't brought it but
Thanksgiving I never cared for
thanksgivingy Stuff turkey sucks
stuffings whatever I I we want pizza
wear a pizza for Thanksgiving people oh
why don't we ask Joe the the famous
pizza question well you know what he's
gonna say yes I need more points on my
side which is The Winning Side from here
on out daddy looks upset because I've
lost this argument but okay now he's
gonna say if you if you knew he was
going to agree with you you would ask
the [__] question yeah of course all
right fine
um you go to you go to an Italian place
that specializes in Coal Fire pizzas
okay okay
um
you so let's say it's you and Sarah you
get some appetizers you share them it
comes time to order dinner okay Sarah
gets the salmon
you get a whole or you get the same he's
not gonna eat this
I eat salmon I like salmon the argument
shouldn't be a place that specializes
and they specialize in Pizza do you
think it's weird to get a pizza as an
entree a pizza just for yourself he's
doing it at Christmas I know she's
stupid I'm all Pizza entree
yes but I don't do it in an Italian
place I'll get a chicken parm or
whatever like a gentleman yeah no you
hate the chicken parm don't try it yeah
the point is is I'm a big chicken bar
man myself the six is three things it's
the best three things no chicken farm is
the best the best dude you still have it
on the plate you can have it on a roll
anything I'm in Lewis Katz just did a
[__] face fronting thing about how he
hates chicken I blocked him again that's
crazy
that's nuts I have a frame photo of him
me and bargatzi on a tank in Kuwait I
ripped it up and threw it up threw it
away the hate that the chicken parm gets
is crazy I've never heard of that in my
life anybody hating chicken he's like he
said to me that kippy's the kind of guy
that goes an entire restaurant gets a
chicken parm it's like yeah the thing on
the menu I'm not sure you're supposed to
do yeah you get if you go to an old
school place you get a chicken parm or
my point is and the last time it's the
last time I'm talking about this I'll
tell you right now because it's
everybody's [__] nuts Pizza is
something theoretically that should be
shared
and when somebody gets that after
appetizers and whatever and gets them as
an entree that's weird
Toby and I both agreed to it no this is
crazy
pizza for one solo this guy's taking
DiGiorno's to the head by the way oh
yeah which I respect that self-rising
crust is all right I mean I never heard
of that one time in my life you get a
pizza I'm eating pizza
you do you yeah I'll do me
you get cookies for eight years
in high school before it was five years
it was score bloated he was
cross-country he had to run
no pizza is an entree of course yeah be
a dessert
I do like those digiornos I like them
that's that's the the one that I have to
have with a couple glasses of milk is it
DiGiorno
Wendy is [__] a couple months later are
you kidding
do you dip it no but the the bite and
sip of that that one that one the most
because the crust is so stupid I do I do
get that you know what I'm talking about
it's a very it's like a pastry yes kind
of crust I mean DiGiorno everything else
is Nostalgia driven it you know they're
good DiGiorno blows everything else away
kills it kills it quality wise yeah um
my I I do I'll do the the self-rising
crust I [__] immediately take two
slices Crush those what do you think's
in that that's probably gonna be
chemicals right now it's not good it's
not healthy it's not good and I go back
I do the third slice and then I leave
the fourth one sitting for out on the
counter until it becomes room
temperature and then I go back and Crush
that like an hour later yeah yeah I love
a DiGiorno I'm thinking I'm gonna get
one tonight it's been a while there you
go it's been a long time
no get out of here come on Ranch I don't
like any I don't like Ray I don't like
ranch or blue cheese and all that
[__] so when you do your wingy when
you get wingies at the cellar you're
you're raw dogging them yeah because
they come with buffalo sauce I don't
need two sauces I'm the same way with
you yeah I might do a little blue cheese
once every five times I might we might
ask this before but is there a better
Wing in New York City than the Olive
Tree blondies is pretty amazing I don't
even know if Blondie still exists but
that was I've heard that the wings at
the cellar are [__] they're very good
crazy good always look so good blondies
was awesome but yeah I love a good Wing
you know what blows me away is that more
places don't have queso like Texas
everywhere has queso you can't find it
anywhere else I think it's like the
dumbest thing Timon loves it so yeah
lava queso will you deal with like the
sausage in it and stuff like that though
no
sausage like chorizo
yeah maybe some beef sausage I don't I
hear sausage I just picture a long dick
sticking out of the cheese
maybe a little couple of Jimmy Deans in
there man your uncle cousin really did a
number on you yeah
oh my God all right this is on food as
well this is from Gary bushwell ten
dollar Banger uh how how we feel about
pepperoni and pasta I've never heard of
that but I wouldn't
throw that out of bed pepperoni and
pasta yeah if you chopped up pepperoni
in a pasta was that a radio Duo
pepperoni and Pasta in the morning that
would be awesome and another universe
back with pepperoni and pasta
and pasta I mean that I just feel like
they're they're [__] with us no he
said his uh wife's family does it they
chop it up and mix it in side note that
just remind me we used to put ice cubes
in SpaghettiOs you ever hear that I
would do it one Ice Cube yeah I would do
it in soup like that those boxes of
Lipton soup yeah I couldn't do that for
the it would make it too watery but I do
love a spaghetti though yeah SpaghettiOs
rule but pepperoni and speaking I've
never heard of that I mean it sounds
like a heartburn City too yeah I can't
imagine I wouldn't hate it I might have
to give it a shot there uh all right
this one's from Sean have you ever used
your non-dominant hand to fake someone
else's handwriting
yes I feel that's the way to go
I don't think that it because you're so
at least for me I'd be so all over that
nobody's gonna question it they think
you're gonna make the letters though I
would have to try to use my dominant
hand and fidget it down do you ever try
to forge your parents signature on
anything no I don't think so I wasn't a
big I was also afraid of getting caught
like it just be that feeling of like ah
Joe listed the principal's office I suck
yeah I was not a forger I knew people
that could do it perfectly
like on a dime you could just copy
somebody's signature I could never do it
I was very lucky my dad's was comically
bad comically comically bad to the point
where it just became known before my
brothers and my sisters went through
that his is so bad that what like I
would get called they would get us you
know they'd be like hey you forged this
and I might they would call my dad and
my dad like no I signed it so like once
that happened I was like oh I can just
[__] they know it's so bad I can just
sign whatever I went in fourth grade we
had a kid that transferred and we became
friends he was a great guy Arch criminal
though literally Arch criminal
um I thought that was his name he would
force RG criminal he at any time he did
really bad but always get in trouble and
anytime he had something to go home he
would sign it like dude you're gonna get
in trouble I'm gonna get in trouble I
finally ended here he's like you know
how I always got away with it it's like
the first one they gave me I signed it
myself so they think that was compared
to that yeah right yeah that's really
smart that's like really thinking it has
yeah that's what I'm telling you yeah
that's diabolical I never had that he's
in jail now oh for sure uh all right
ones from Zach uh what workout equipment
is allowed to be on the front porch just
a couple of dumbbells a bench press a
Bowflex I don't think anything now come
on maybe some some dumbbells I'd give
you if you're out there you know
popping up the guns but if there's like
a wall on the port like that half wall
yeah that's what I'm saying maybe yeah
maybe exercise bike ah anything there's
a couch on that porch too for sure
getting a Pit Bull with no collar yeah
chewing a tire and a beware of dog sign
on a screen door with no screen yeah
outdoor exercise equipment's a tough
look yeah that should be in a basement
but then like it's like if you live in
like you know a small home like in
Queens or something like a you know a
single like a row home or whatever where
are you gonna put it in your dining room
like I kind of jammed up I guess so but
I think yeah it's not time for you to
work out at home
got a plan of Fitness yeah just I mean
like picking up a a plate and ripping
grass at the same time just feels a
little weird you're like on a bench
press it's uneven because it's on a hill
I don't know anybody working out on
their front porch is in and out of
prison yeah right I'm picturing the
white the wife being of course yeah I
don't think they're too concerned with
curb appeal either they're just like I'm
get I gotta get this in that's a tough
look I just picture your parole officer
walking up what it's not Tuesday yeah
been here all day I yeah I gotta say I'm
that's that's a problem that guy yeah
it's bad news sorry no I can't abide all
right let's do one or two more here uh
this one's from garbage Emeritus uh when
the remote control dot when the remote
control dies is a garbage to replace
only one battery instead of both of them
that's the move I've been yeah
I never heard of that yeah it just needs
a if you can't if you don't have another
because I think this is based on the
scarcity of batteries huh if you have to
like take it out of something else you
only put it in one I think the rule with
that is okay the remote dies you take
the batteries out and put them back in
that's the first thing you can get a
little more juice out sure sometimes you
swap them then you start doing test by
test you do the one see if it works you
do the other one see if it works and
you're taking that from something
another remote that's not coming from a
fresh pack of batteries yeah who the
[__] had that
now my mom has a toolbox that has like
400 batteries in it all for dildos
my dad worked at a hospital he was in
charge of purchasing that was his thing
his occupation so we always had bet he
would take batteries I hope I'm not
blowing up his [__] you're not not
blowing up she's still work there we had
drawer at a different hospital
um
drawers full of batter that was like the
one real real uh that's a pretty solid
perk it was good and oh you guys are
gonna love this that's why they were
okay throwing five bucks at night on
Burger King for you getting all that
battery saving all that battery money it
was in a drawer where we kept the uh
whatever China we had it was like a
china cabinet china cabinet it was in a
China cabinet drawer so it'd be China
and batteries so ours were there too in
the dining room what else was it was
there actual China in the china cabinet
did you guys have nice plates tongue
depressors and rubber gloves
so we kept the MRI machine it wasn't
fine but it was it was something it was
like yeah it was Tibet
it was pronounced so low
it was so it was adjacent to China South
Korean plates it was uh yeah it was
Mongolian uh when would they be broken
out what would the occasion have to be
at the list house never my parents did
have one but it was almost like a cigar
bar they must have been a wedding gift
from somebody that was like actual I
think silver China was it in one of
those boxes it was in a box yeah nice
and it was never used ever I mean we
were like a paper plates eating Celeste
Pizza family but someone must have given
it to them and it must still exist
somewhere I'm sure maybe I'll get it all
right couple of bucks walking in for
dinner grabbing the Channel with the
McRibs back
break out the good plates no I do
remember it I do remember that it never
was
it was never used never allowed to be
touched yeah but it was it was there it
was somewhere
all right well we gotta wrap it up gang
buddy we love you to death yeah that's
always a [__] fun hang
congratulations on the special fantastic
enough for everybody yes out on YouTube
right now do yourself a favor you got to
see Joe you got to see him live listen
you know what you know him he's one of
the [__] best working buddy we love
you thank you very much I love you guys
what else you got coming up you want
anybody to know hit him uh I got a bunch
of fun dates Nashville Philly October
5th there you go yeah [__] let's go
yeah Joe list right before the baby cubs
so helium October 5th through the 7th
and uh Nashville September 21st the 23rd
I think it is at uh zany so those can be
fun and uh you guys at skank Fest we're
not there
oh son of an onion well albeit skank
Fest sad uh but completely upset and
then Royal Oak I think right before the
baby I think October like 21st and 22nd
like a week before the new baby coming
this kid's killing it I'm scared to
death
can't be what do you got for him uh gang
like we said in the beginning we're all
over the road shows are [__] selling
out thank you shout out to the [__]
we love the army of garbage baby we're
out of the second show at the Fillmore
in Philadelphia get those [__]
tickets yeah let's go fish we are out of
the third show in Toronto Chicago's
third show is about to go we're gonna
add a fourth there get those [__]
tickets gang gang we'll see you next
week peace